[Music]
come on yes sir please look here all
aboard the failing grayling Express next
stop absolute incompetence hardly a week
goes by without another cock-up
by transport secretary Chris Grayling in
the last week alone he's got the blame
for the government having to give 33
million pounds of taxpayers money to
Eurotunnel
his privatization of the Probation
Service when justice secretary was
revealed to have cost a hundred and
seventy million pounds and five local
authorities some of them Tory accused
him of a giant can't over Heathrow's
third one way but this is nothing new
for mr. grayling after all he was the
minister blamed last summer for the
chaos caused when the rail timetables
were redrawn and he was widely mocked
when he when he awarded and later
withdrew a government ferry contractor
to Seaborn fate a company that had no
ships and the never man a ferry service
the only thing going in his favor is
that he did run mrs. baines campaign to
become Prime Minister that was a real
success but his graining merely a total
incompetent or has he just been unlucky
what all these mistakes his fault what
were some of them at least the
responsibility of a series of anonymous
civil servants when something goes
seriously wrong should we always blame
it on an individual minister that does
let the officials go scot-free
[Music]
very interesting point you make they're
very interesting because how much is the
boss actually responsible for what goes
on for his or her band beneath them but
let's actually hear from the man himself
this is Chris Grayling speaking on
Sophie Ridge on Sunday in January why do
you think it is that this kind of
misfortune seems to follow you
well it's a challenging time for all of
us in government we have to deliver
change we have to tackle new issues like
padrone's for example so it's a question
of getting on with the job and tackling
the problems that best you can but the
end of the day dealing with your
financial positions and also dealing
with particular challenges like the
expanding demand on the railways you
just gotta get on with the job and do
your best and to keep the theme going
with your excellent Fat Controller
pastiche or whatever it was I have to
bring in on platform one we hear the
current prisons minister say
transforming rehabilitation is meant we
are now monitoring forty thousand more
offenders than we were in the past this
is good for public safety on platform -
Chris Grayling said not a penny of
taxpayers money has gone or will go to
Seabourn Freight upon platform three he
said the No Deal Loree trial worked fine
and served its purpose in testing how
quickly lawyers could leave the test
site over on platform for regarding the
Eurotunnel payment he said the
government took a decision in the best
interest of the country to prepare for a
No Deal brexit and lastly at platform
five on Heathrow the Department of
Transport said they are confident that
fewer people will be affected by a new
noise pollution under the new flight
paths plan in summary I think you're
right I think a lot of people are
probably getting away and they shouldn't
be but ultimately ultimately at this
level if you carry the brief you should
carry the responsibility as well and I
think as well you say one could be a
mistake to his misfortune or whatever
there are too many hanging around but
every so often I mean I thought this
thing on drones I mean you imagine you
have a minister you're sitting there
you're not having a bad week
no one's been go over and suddenly
someone starts flying a drone around
Gatwick Airport and you get the blame
and you think I probably never heard of
he's the comet the political version of
mr. bean you know a great quote and
respect senator sweet words it said that
Dunkirk could have been very different
if great but you know the Seaborn thing
this was so you know you
both mentioned that the people behind
him in the in the Department of
Transport if say if either grayling or
his civil servants who are in that in
that department among the highest paid
in the government and if they had just
done due diligence not only of what they
have found out that Seaborn had no boat
so they found out that Ben Sharpe is one
of the directors of the company also has
another company who's gone bust
owing lots of money to the tax man he
has another companies which has quotes
technically insolvent and seaboard
itself only had 35 grand in assets so
it's clearly not the people for the job
but you wouldn t expect the minister to
be doing that degree of leisure but his
department at Smyth put his department
the people ordering I do not do some
checks on it we got here what we got
here is a geezer and I taught it the
Midas touch in Reverse right everybody
touches turns are the obvious all right
I remember young private sold you like
this right and everything he did was
useless they they ended up they took him
out of a rifle company which is a
fighting company because he just kept
didn't everything wrong they put him in
the parachute display team he fell out
the plane early was nothing he wasn't on
he then tried to stop the props with a
ladder
the guy was a naps they had to find a
job the finest key to another job and I
think they'd be fair mr. Gradin you've
had your chance but you could definitely
do with jogging on the walking dead
dreams do you know do you know that he
went stateside this week the New York
Times ran a story with headline how does
he survive failure engraving and they
said he's becoming a byword for hapless
men of Golden Age of political
blundering something we don't want
representing a beat and then I came
across this form and assume B C that was
the difference about the factory
government people talk about the
Thatcher era and everything else
remember the great big beasts there that
the people of real ability like the Ken
Clark's
the Michael Heseltine's these were
mighty mighty political animals
can you find me now well it's got Chris
Grayling Chris Grayling see I can now be
really rude about some of these really
to God I mean a man who makes has made
the whole career that says that Vance on
pitiful failure after failure and it's
like he's gonna screw it up let me just
figure this poll here there's a poll of
satisfaction among Tory party members
her Andrea let's um gets plus 55 percent
Jeremy hung gets close 47 railing gets
minus 60 serious side to this so that
New York Times story I was telling you
about they they they put they printed
that they've calculated that he'd cost
the British taxpayer 1.7 million they
then had to correct it to 1.7 billion
countability if this cup I was working
at a big company you know any would he
be fine but the CEO who let him operate
I hate to bring in the B word but it's
because Theresa May can't afford to lose
a brexit ear who's not associate but
you've seen this before have yet sudden
suddenly there is a politician and
everything goes wrong and everything
they touch goes wrong I don't think this
is you can save them really I think but
isn't it like you're all game football
you're a manager or the cards go against
you and you just he's done for now it's
just surely it's just a matter of time I
think he's still going employ and he
can't knock him for that season I you've
only got five picks you tears left in
your cabinet you can't afford to lose
one yeah I remember a former
commissioner of the Met once saying to
me that despite everything that he was
doing in the success and the detectives
it just takes one loony copper to do
something stupid Bromley and its whole
career tumble as you wonder whether
that's actually fair okay Abbott what is
it
man when you meet him I like him no I
think I think is the most unremarkable I
wish you say that without everyone I'm
and the BBC yes people were sitting
there having an okay week and there's
suddenly somebody in Cardiff does
something you've never heard of and the
world comes down and on you now it's
it's worse you know
in a government post because our whole
government system protects the civil
service